now throwing heads is a real thing it's
definitely an intimidation tactic when
the first crusade reached nicaea
in 1097 both the attackers and defenders
threw heads at each other hi i'm dr
michael fulton i'm an expert at siege
warfare and medieval fortifications
today we're going to be looking at
hassle battle scenes in movies and tv
and judging how real they are
there's nothing far-fetched about
sneaking into a castle or town there are
ways to do that whether you're disguised
as somebody or you're hiding in
something
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of runs to the edge and says hey
you stop that there's a traditional
phenomenon called castle watch you're
really just watching making sure that
nobody sneaks up on uh your castle what
you're trying to defend your castle
against is a large army
because it's very hard to take a castle
unless you have a large army it's hard
to sneak up on a castle if you're coming
with an army people know that army is
coming
[Applause]
i think this is supposed to be killed
drummy castle which
by this point had a very elaborate gate
system
so just
opening that gate
would have been quite a challenge
everybody's going to go to that gate a
gate like that would have been a whole
structure so each gate to that structure
would presumably have been locked by
someone on the inside
the idea of this small party trying to
rush against this small group that are
in the great hall
i kind of don't understand because a
castle of this scale is going to have a
lot more defenders and you're going to
have to overcome them all
so your priority is really seeing the
strategic parts of the castle the great
hall is not really one of them sleeping
in the or on the floor of the great hall
was a traditional thing to do it's
starting to go out of fashion by this
point in history but if you were to look
back at say the 11th 12th century the
king's retainers or the lords retainers
his kind of high-ranking guys would
have a lot of drinking parties and then
just kind of pass out on the floor
around
there would be weapons around
you wouldn't need to necessarily don
your armor
in order to defend a castle like this
that's much more helpful in an open
battle maybe a two if i'm being generous
stay alive the little screens there
those were very important because they
just stopped arrows
[Music]
the moat or the ditch this is
the most basic
fortification element other than some
kind of a basic wall um this was
supposed to be the castle at shenlong
it's up on a hill so i'm not sure if it
would have needed a ditch but if it
looked at all like this where the ground
is kind of nice and approachable leading
up you're absolutely gonna have a ditch
because it's so easy
they put a lot of effort in hanging
these incendiaries on the gate why don't
you just put it at the bottom of the
gate
setting gates on fire is
a legitimate tactic here it largely
predates this period though if you have
incendiaries during this period they are
more likely to look like tar
than like well presumably like gasoline
because you have to refine it
portcullis has disappeared for some
reason
so the portcullis design like that with
that lattice structure that was coming
into fashion around this time
whether it is
wood that has been kind of coated with
metal
or plated or whether it's entirely metal
you see both variations the whole point
of it though is that it is open so you
can stick stuff through it if you want
and if it's metal presumably it means
you can't set it on fire which is
critical here right
traditionally the gate is the weakest
part of a fortified enclosure because
it's a hole right so
you need to
strengthen that hole to make sure that
it's not a point of weakness or
vulnerability so through the 13th
century gates actually become the
strongest part of a castle instead of
the weakest port just because of the
level of development that goes into it
kind of walking up to a gate trying to
set it on fire trying to use a ram
against it
they've had a long time to think about
these kind of siege tactics and to
develop fortifications accordingly so
it's kind of anachronistic order the
siege tactics are already a little bit
outdated in this representation these
guys are trying they haven't pulled it
all together
as best as they could i'd give them
somewhere five six
[Music]
these are terrible catapults the stones
seem to somehow speed up as they leave
the basket should slow down from that
point if you look at how big this chunk
of stone is
it's significantly larger than the
engine that's supposed to be throwing it
now throwing heads is a real thing
this is an element of psychological
warfare it's definitely an intimidation
tactic when the first crusade reached
nicaea
in 1097 both the attackers and defenders
threw heads at each other it took place
more often when you had
groups facing off from different
cultures
[Music]
don't put a trebuchet a big
counterweight style trebuchet on top of
a tower for a few reasons it is heavy so
the tower actually has to be able to
support the weight of the engine you get
a little bit more range but that
horizontal range is actually less than
the vertical uh height that you've
elevated the engine if you put it on the
ground behind the tower all of a sudden
you don't have to worry about supporting
this engine in all its stresses and you
actually get the uh shielding of the
wall in front to protect it from uh the
enemies machines who are presumably
trying to to break it up there is this
desire or need to make them really big
and really impressive so these were
important weapons but nowhere near as
exciting as hollywood loves to make them
out to be
to attack a big curved wall it's just
like attacking any other wall rounded
towers are designed
purposely to deflect incoming artillery
and such cohesively a rounded tower is
stronger because it doesn't have corners
so you don't have the same kind of
points of stress so if you're trying to
undermine a tower a round tower is
slightly stronger than a uh a square one
cities built on cliffs that you'd attack
why don't you just build on top of the
cliff as real as an orc siege of a
make-believe city can be i'm still gonna
have to give this one out of ten
[Applause]
night attacks
can take place there's nothing to say
that they didn't or that they shouldn't
are they trying to go through a gate
there are three ways to overcome a wall
you can go over it which case you use
ladders siege towers stuff like that you
can go under it which is
not a great strategy because then kind
of emerging on the other side one by one
if you tunnel under or you can go
through and the best way to go through
is actually to undermine the wall dig a
big cavity underneath the wall you prop
up the wall above with wooden posts
you throw a bunch of combustibles in all
that support gets burnt out the wall
above falls down
lighting arrows on fire like this
hollywood loves to do it serves no
practical value unless you're trying to
set a thatched roof cottage on fire
so they kind of got up to the base of
the wall here this is a safe spot in so
much as it's hard for archers to shoot
arrows at them from here but you can
just drop some stones over on them it's
economical if you consider that every
arrow has to be made by hand that's not
a short process to make an arrow so when
they're throwing off all these volleys
of arrows and shooting them off as fast
as they can that's not very efficient
you drop a bowling ball on somebody and
it stops them in their tracks
defenders exit a gate and try and attack
the procedures
that's reasonably common the issue here
is why
you would only do this if you needed to
those attackers didn't have the numbers
they probably needed to overcome these
defenses to begin with
in the medieval period leadership is
directly tied to
military performance in prowess so for a
commander they have to be aware of
what's going on
uh if they are kind of a warrior figure
which the most effective military kings
usually were so having someone on top of
the wall
organizing things
definitely not beyond the realm of
possibility
i don't quite see
what they're going to accomplish
once they reach the base of this wall
so i'm gonna give this one maybe a
three out of ten
this is the siege of rochester 12 15.
do whatever you can uh
to help your side get through because if
you're then left alone on that wall
you're gonna be killed yourself um so
the very worst thing you can do is get
to the top of the wall and then be left
alone this way
rarely you find women actually taking a
direct role in the fighting but
you do find relatively frequent examples
of women will bring
weapons and supplies to people fighting
they bring particularly water and food
so there's absolutely a role for these
kind of people to play the church is a
very logical place for them to be if
they're not taking part in the fighting
at this time
the importance or the centrality of god
in a conflict like this would have been
huge they were too cold to fight
and too hungry
sieges would last anywhere from kind of
weeks to months when an army moves into
enemy territory if there are crops it
will destroy them for those inside the
defensive perimeter they're forced to
make do with the food that they have
very rarely did strongholds actually
fall by force the outer line of defenses
might fall
but then those that are still in the
innermost part will surrender if the
attackers are not able to impose a
complete blockade there might be
actually supplies coming in to support
the defenders throughout the siege you
get this in particularly when you're
talking about bigger cities being
attacked
i've gotta give them a four or five out
of ten
this is not what paris looked like at
the time the big church in the
background this is high gothic
the palace right next to it this looks
suspiciously like the papal palace in
avignon which is 14th century not 9th
century
i certainly love using the crossbows
there's anecdotal evidence here that
they were kind of introduced to the
franks at this point so you've got guys
kind of leaning through the kernels like
this which are the spaces between the
merlins the teeth on the walls and at
what point they came into use
these
would have been around at this point
so penthouses like these that they're
using for shelter are
very important this is a safe way to
kind of get to the base of the walls of
a city
usually what you'd use these for
particularly in later periods is
undermining the city walls so it's a
means of getting up to the city walls
and then trying to dig a hole under them
how strong is this gate because really
these are just some planks
horses are
important the significance of mounted
warriors is really growing throughout
this period in a siege though horses
tend not to be terribly useful eating
they need to be fed they produce waste
which needs to be dealt with
so siege towers
are an important
siege weapon in warfare
they are a great way to get people into
an elevated position the primary
function of a siege tower really is to
elevate attackers as opposed to trying
to get them to the top of a wall
that might be a handy secondary purpose
hiding behind their parapet
so here
it's very helpful
but a ladder would be a much cheaper and
cost-effective manner to get up to the
top
so i would rate this somewhere around i
don't know three or four and the siege
technologies aren't exactly that
accurate
[Music]
it wouldn't be
uncommon to have castle gates open if
you were
just guarding this gate against any kind
of troublemakers
it's very believable that the guards
would be down on the bottom floor it's a
lot easier to chase somebody down if
you're already down there
for him to go around killing people
indiscriminately
that actually makes sense
once someone gets into the fortified
enclosure there's no protection for
those within
unless some kind of peace agreement is
pre-arranged so the whole point of a
castle is you're having walls do the
work of defenders the whole market kind
of environment
would usually be outside the castle the
environment inside the castle is
catering only to those really who live
there or might need to take refuge there
it was a matter of protecting who was in
charge
you don't often find cases where
someone is lauded for
single-handedly capturing a castle or
some other fortification
more often you will find individuals
praise for their conduct
the first person to set foot on a
defender's wall so if you're the first
one up on your ladder first one up on
your siege tower usually that person
gets special mention to take a castle
kind of like we associate them or we
picture them
you're gonna need a force in at least
the hundreds probably the thousands
i have no idea what to offer this one i
believe this is a real castle it's
setting about a very kind of
rose-colored glasses
day in the life of a castle it's trying
i don't know
lobbing arrows at a distance is not an
effective siege tactic or counter siege
tactic so when you see archers they pull
an arrow they knock it they draw and
then they kind of hold then they shoot
their errors all at once this is again
this is inspired by later musket tactics
where you have lines of musketeers
shooting off volleys
for the same reason that you would wait
until the attackers got closer to shoot
a musket at them
well a ladder is just propped up against
the wall they'd actually be quite sturdy
um and you'd reuse them sometimes so
this would have been a difficult tactic
but a believable one
so the easiest way to try and make sure
that ladder doesn't get used is either
break the ladder somehow which is kind
of hard given the angles involved or to
take a long stick and just try and push
the ladder to the point where it goes
past the hor or past the vertical and
falls over backwards so that's very
believable
[Music]
so you do have certain accounts of
machines like these that will
in some way
hold something
not friendly
over the walls and then drop it on
the attackers
usually they're deployed against a siege
tower or something a little bit more
impressive because if it's just kai's
coming up a ladder you just drop some
stones on them you often find them in
kind of or being associated with sailors
you effectively have a mast and then a
yard of some description and it will
then be swung out over the wall
and using rigging that sailors would be
accustomed to they can then drop
something on the attackers the
descriptions of these vary sometimes
it's kind of a ring that's on fire
other times it's something really heavy
other times you have
just a log with spikes kind of being
hoisted or tossed over the wall
i'm not an expert of east asian warfare
but
there's some good elements to this
there's also you know the obvious
fantasy aspect to it so i don't know
maybe four or ten